hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts differentiation
synthesizes stem alike glioblastoma
tumor initiating cells to mechanical
inputs
presented by Jasmine Hughes a PhD
candidate in the UC Berkeley UCSF
graduate program in bioengineering
I am susie Valdez of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit them at thermo Fisher com
now let's get started before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want as anytime during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click on the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits and now like to introduce
our presenter Jasmine Hughes Jasmine
Hughes is a PhD candidate in the UC
Berkeley UCSF graduate program in bio
engineering and is working in the
laboratory of Professor Sanjay Kumar at
the University of California Berkeley
jasmine is interested in how cells sense
and respond to the mechanical properties
of their micro environment she answers
open questions in mechanical biology by
designing and applying novel synthetic
biology and systems biology tools she's
particularly interested in how
mechanically regulated signaling is
perturbed in glioblastoma stem like
tumor initiating cells Jasmine received
her bachelor's degree in chemical in
earrings from McGill University and has
been recognized for her work by the
natural scientists and Engineering
Research Council of Canada and by the
Siebel Scholars foundation in addition
to her academic pursuits jasmine also
played a leadership role in advancing
professional development opportunities
for Berkeley PhDs to the nonprofit
organization beyond academia Jasmine you
may now begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction and thank
you to all of you guys for tuning in I'm
really excited to talk about one of the
projects that I've been working on for
my PhD where we're particularly looking
at career blastoma tumor initiating
cells look at that into that in a little
bit more detail I am actually a chemical
engineer by training and I think that
that background has given me a different
way of looking at cancer cells some sort
of like a force balance perspective and
I really enjoyed the biology part of my
chemical engineering training so I
switched into bioengineering so I'm
excited to talk to you about I have has
well some sources and things like that
so glioblastoma is the most common and
lethal primary brain cancer is an
aggressive malignant cancer of glial
cells in the last 15 years we've made a
lot of technological advances so this
includes the introduction of chemo to
Mozilla Meyde and more aggressive tissue
removal surgeries that are guided by
improved imaging technologies however
recurrences near-universal despite these
technological advances and radiation
therapy leading median survival time at
just about 15 months so one of the
problems that faces that we have when
you're treating group loss coma is that
the cells are able to migrate through
the tissue which makes it very difficult
for us to surgically remove when you
take us all they're able to then
re-establish the tumor which is what you
see sort of at the borders of the tumor
resection those in the 12 months 17
months images here and this process is
ultimately fatal so part of what's
fought to govern this tumor
reestablishment is the presence of tumor
initiating cells which are sometimes
also called tumor stem cells so these
cells evade treatment invade through the
tissue and recapitulate the original
tumor so these cells are has been shown
to migrate along white matter tracks in
the brain and along blood vessels and
other structures in the brain that have
differences in mechanical properties and
that's led to some people to wonder how
these cells
the mechanical properties of their
environment so we've looked at a lot of
we've identified key genes and soluble
factors and this has led to a lot of
insights on how to treat these cells but
the some thought that maybe if you
better understood being mechanical
sensitivity process we might better
understand how to treat these cells
so one of the key techniques that we use
in this field to look at how cells sense
mechanical cues are the use of things
like probably fill my gels and other
biomaterials where we can vary the
mechanical properties of them by varying
their composition how to cross-linked so
one of the seminal works in this field
came from now over a decade ago
when Patrick and colleagues discovered
that matrix stiffness perturbed tissue
structures such as in these asinine
shown here these are MTF 10,000 3d2 gel
culture and this increased matrix
stiffness promoted a more malignant
phenotype so this work and the work by
many others in the field have led to
this model shown on the right in which
genetic mutations and tick fishing
mechanical structure produce a positive
feedback loop leads to malignant tumors
so this process can begin within
oncogenic mutations that's the left of
this diagram and this mutation needs to
have changes in how cells sense
mechanical cues or how they remodel the
extracellular matrix in their
environment or alternatively on the
right side of this diagram this process
can begin to changes to the normal
structure that extracellular matrix such
as from chronic for versus leading to
the acquisition of oncogenic mutations
so regardless of which path you get to
begin with he then gets a sort of a
feedback loop of mechanical signals and
genetic mutations and this creates an
environment the votes promotes the
growth survival and invasion so over the
last couple decades we've greatly
increased our understanding of how cells
spend mechanical changes in our
environment and these are largely
thought to occur through actin myosin
contractility the cells have an actin
myosin cytoskeleton
so filaments actin cross-linked with
monkey my salute to and
cells are constantly pulling on their
environment this force that's generated
by a myosin motor proteins is
transmitted to the extracellular matrix
through complexes or contact points
known as focal adhesions
so this force balance between exercise
matrix and the fourth generation cell is
interpreted by the cell into a diverse
array of phenotypes that include cell
shape proliferation and migration
so one of the major signaling pathways
through which the cop cell contractile
forces are regulated the bro pathway
where ro a activates myosin light-chain
but through phosphorylation and this
leads to life and being able to go to
contractile force and that leads to
mechana sensing so typically the soft
substrates such as the brain are
translated in by the cell into reduced
migration and reduce proliferation which
acts as a bit of stop signal that's kind
of an interesting question for an glioma
where the brain is obviously or
glioblastoma or where the brain is
obviously a very sick soft substrate so
how is that influencing glioma cells so
a few years ago we took a glioblastoma
following
u-87 in two to seven threes and we put
them onto cell gels of different
stiffness so very soft which is 80
Pascal on the left or very stiff which
is 119 kPa as stiffness is higher than
this we actually wouldn't see much of a
difference in the phenotype so what we
found is that in agreement with climbing
in most other cell types these cells
showed a very strong sensitivity to
mechanical signals so on the very stiff
substrates they had these very spread
morphologies they had very prominent
actin myosin stress fibers shown in
green and they had prominent focal
patient's there's the contact points to
exercise our matrix on various soft
substrates they had that rounded
morphology they didn't have prominent
stress fibers that you had very small
focal adhesions so this was also true
for other behaviors that are known to be
mechanically regulated so cell speed for
example is very strongly
mechanosensitive and proliferation so as
measured by incorporation of brdu
is also very intensive so these were
continuous cell lines and that's
important when you're thinking about
cancer biology is of course because you
cells are cultured in serum and they've
been passage many times and are at this
point fairly far removed from you know
physiological brain tumor cells
in fact if you put these cells into
mouth frame in a xenograft model they
don't really even form classically lost
oh my like tumors they have they're kind
of more circumscribed compact smaller
tumors so because of these differences
you wanted to make sure that this also
is still upheld at a more sort of
physiological model level so we turn to
patient derived stem cells so these this
is a collaboration with Brent Reynolds
lab in Florida and their cells that have
been harvested from donated surgically
removed glioblastoma tissue so we select
these cells by growing them in a
neurospheres suspension culture medium
and this is supplemented with a high
concentration of epidermal growth factor
and fibroblast growth factors eg F and F
G OH so these cells Express stem markers
like Fox 2 Aniston for example but
particularly importantly if you were to
xenograph them into mice then they form
B cells form tumors with the classic
homeworks of glioblastoma so that
includes areas necrosis diffuse
migration through the brain tissue
around it to Palace feeding structures
so when you put these cells on her gels
the very soft ones and very stiff ones
we notice that they actually didn't form
stress fibers on these either stiffness
particularly they didn't have
differences in their focal adhesions and
more importantly they're kind of
similarly spread on all of the different
stiffnesses we then looked at migration
as well and it was still a little bit
mechanosensitive but not to the same
dramatic effect that we've seen before
so they're still fairly able to migrate
on soft substrates
we have host a proliferation again with
incorporation of brdu and we also didn't
see a mechanical difficulty regulating
difference in proliferation so because
these cells weren't forming the stress
fibers and the so quotations that we
normally expect to see from self
generating contractile forces on stiff
matrices we wonder if perhaps these
cells were generating smaller amounts of
contractile force we wondered if we were
able to change that so we turned it to
the row rock pathway and we about what
happens if we increase the amount of
myosin light-chain phosphorylation we
took a doxycycline inducible
cassette and we genetically engineered
ourselves to be able to induce
expression of Rho a this is actually a
constantly active mutant or grow a third
always on in the cell and we found that
when we activated our way by introducing
doxycycline into the media we were able
to increase the phosphorylation levels
of the myosin light-chain and when you
put ourselves be activated Rho a
machinery we found that we could induce
a level of mccanna sensitivity which is
really interesting to see so these cells
are the control cells were equally
spread on the soft matrices and on the
stiff matrices but the conchiglie active
Rho a cells be activated myosin
contractility were much more round on
the soft gels compared to on the stiff
gel so this also held true for for
migration as well and we then wondered
if that would lead to differences in
invasion as well we did a three
dimensional migration assays so so how
looking at how the cells move through
three dimensional collagen so the
control cells when you put a little
steroid into three dimensional college
and they start to invade pretty well
they're fairly invasive cells and the in
contrast the digitally active railway
cells they remained very tight into
their to neurospheres that didn't invade
to the matrix we next looked at turns on
migration which is also sort of a metric
of how well those able to invade we
found that by activating the row a
pathway we could reduce the amount of
migration through a trend so this was
kind of promising for
cancer biology reasons and we wondered
if this would also hold true a still a
more physiologically relevant model so
we turned to new xenograph
that we've been doing before so the
control cells forms these classical
glioblastoma tumors large is diffuse
migration away from the core and also
some migrations to the other side of the
brain and in contrast the roadway cells
forms much smaller and circumscribed
tumors with very clear boundaries and we
didn't be establishment of secondary
tumors this translated to a much smaller
amount of tumor occupancy in the brain
and extended mass survival time so what
we have share is sort of this
observation that these cells are not
mechanosensitive and that by increasing
the activity of the optimizing
contractility we could increase the
mechanical sensitivity and also
decreased tumor migration so this made
us what
wonder because of those really striking
relationships because between the can of
sensitivity and invasion we wanted to
better understand the relationship
because between stemness and Meccano
sensitivity so as the mechanicals to be
property linked to the fact that these
cells are sort of stem like so one
morphogen of particular interest is bone
morphogenic protein for which has been
established as a sigma 1q that's
important in neural development and it
also plays a role in the adult neural
stem cell Miche this is a region that is
flat to give rise to a sizable
proportion of glioblastoma this is a
particularly interesting or tumor
initiating cells
so another lab has looked at the role
that bmp4 plays in tumor initiating
genome tumor initiating cells they found
that if you treat the cells that bmp4
they stop forming neurospheres which is
an indication that they lose some of
their stem white properties but also
importantly they show an increase in the
expression of differentiation records so
for example they show an increase in GF
ap which is an astrocyte marker and
increase in beta tubulin 3 which is a
neural marker i also saw an increase in
calcium which is an illiquid venture
site marker at level up to a smaller
extent also right interesting you treat
yourself as being before they stop being
able to form these glioblastoma tumors
but the tumors that do form are very
small compact
so we wonder what happens if you treat
ourselves with bmp4
do they retain their Meccano in
sensitivity or today and now become able
to contract their environment and
interpret those signals so what we found
is that when we treat ourselves with
being before they actually do become a
little bit more cata sensitive so in
general the cells are smaller when
treated to the mp4 but they become able
to sense the differences and stiffnesses
so now they're rounded on top matrices
and spread on stick so sort of a classic
phenotype that you'd expect from the cat
associate itself
we wondered if this would also translate
to other readouts mechanic sensitivity
so one that's become increasingly used
in the field is check location of
mechanosensitive transcription factors
this is sort of a hallmark paper in the
field where they found that the
transcription factors Yap and tag go to
the nucleus on stiff substrates but on
soft substrates like the one on the
right here they tend to be more
cytoplasmic so this has been replicated
by a number of labs although I think for
most people the difference has been
quite as clear-cut in most cell lines
was true for ours as well we've looked
at neural stem cells they behave very
similarly so what we found is that for
the growth factor treated cells on soft
or the stiff matrices there Tad's
localization was mostly set of plasmic
with a little bit of nuclear staining as
well however on the stiff substrates
we've had an increase in nuclear
localization so particularly you can see
that on the bottom right of these cells
here so this suggested to us that there
was perhaps some role that transcription
was playing in ourselves on the stiff
matrices
so we wanted to know kind of what what
was going on in these cells what's
changing when they differentiate is
there a transcriptionally regulated
reasons these cells might be more
McKenna sentence so to get in sort of a
snapshot idea of what these cells are
going through we did RNA sequencing so
we looked at cells on either the soft
matrices or on the stiff matrices and
that have been treated either with the
growth factors or with bmp4
to do the one-week differentiation we
should be fairly differentiate at this
point as the what we so if found is that
bp4 elicits pronounced transcriptomic
respect I don't think that's
particularly surprising since we are
sort of sending these cells into a
differentiated condition this is a
volcano plot this log fold change in the
bottom and then adjust a p-value on the
y-axis and the orange dots are the jean
genet the genes that have been
differentially expressed so what we
found is that there's a very large
number of genes that are similarly
influenced by BP for regardless of
stiffness which you can see in the bed
diagram on the left there's also yes
some genes that are unique to cell
differentiate on soft and phone gene
turn to those different rate constants
particularly interesting to us is the
effect of mechanical properties of the
environment so these volcanic lots
should the difference between the stiff
versus soft for BMP treated on the left
and then on the right is for the gross
character treat itself so what we found
is that this sort of a three fold
increased number of transcripts that are
differentially expressed on software
sister for the BMP four cells compared
to the growth factor to itself so that
tells us that yes in fact being before
sensitizes these cells to the chemicals
but
I think what was kind of surprising to
us however is that there was very few
genes that were Macau sensitive in both
the growth factor treated condition as
well as the bmp4 treated condition
most of these were higher expressed on
disk so these was the genes shown in
orange we also found that we had to sort
of expected changes in stem markers like
colic too
and we found the expected changes in
differentiation workers like beta
tubulin and GAAP there were a couple
markers that we looked at that we
expected to see changes in so that's
particularly Fox 2 and gal C so sucks
tears of some marker this in some
literature is that that flux to
expression doesn't actually change
during differentiation of glioblastoma
tumor initiating cells and this is it's
thought that even despite her
differentiation signals these cells
still try to retain some of their sort
of stem-cell plasticity and that's
important for cancer progression so
while this finding was initially
surprising to us I think that it's
backed up by other groups as well and
then we didn't see changes in Chelsea
which is an all identified marker so
from prior papers we've also noticed
that this doesn't change that much
during differentiation of these cells so
working to surprising that we didn't see
significant differences and rna-seq
so we wanted to get an idea of which
pathways are being changed by the mp4
and if that could change could explain
any of these changes in mechanic
sensitivity so what we found is that we
looked at the pathways that are
over-represented in the genes that are
significantly differentially expressed
after being p4 treatments we found that
ECM receptor interaction came up at the
top so this is kind of interesting to
suggest that being p4 influences how the
cell is ripping onto the environment how
its producing environment around it for
example we also found that the genes
that are differentially expressed
particularly tend to localize to the
stress fibers focal adhesions cell
Philip's your instructions but all of us
really support the model where this BMP
forward differentiation influences how
cells are gripping on to their
environment and that could maybe explain
some of the more phenotypic differences
that I've shown previously I think sort
of as McKenna biologists we were
particularly interested and what changes
as a result of mechanic sensitivity so
we did the same sort of analysis looking
at what happens or what how the genes
that are differentially expressed by
stiffness like what pathways are ours we
see there so we looked and we found that
ribosomes and genes related to oxidative
phosphorylation are particularly
enriched and meet this gene class as
well as a couple of other diseases so
Parkinson's disease on Alzheimer's
disease and Huntington's disease our own
genes are all diseases of oxidative
phosphorylation so I'll kind of group
those into my discussions going forward
the genes that are overrepresented in
Makena sensitivity also tend to localize
to ribosomes to the extracellular matrix
focal fusions and to the microchip so
again that's kind of um yes reinforcing
so this idea that differentiation
influences how cells are gripping on
their environment and that mccanna
sensitive
or mechanical cues influence I guess
energy production and translation so
what we notice is that oxidative
phosphorylation genes tend to be down
regulated by B and P 4 and up regulated
on stress substrates while ribosomal
proteins are up regulated by being P 4
and on stuff substrate
so we wanted to verify this at the
protein levels we did some Western blots
we picked a couple of Canada genes that
were particularly associated with the
pathways that we've seen before so value
CM communication so we list add
affection in one map two kinase Tazz and
vixen and we saw the gene expression
change in the direction that we had
expected so encouraging
we also looked at integrand off of two I
think this is particularly an
interesting marker because it's up
regulated by being p4 and its
transcription is also different at
different stiffnesses so we look to see
if it held true also the protein level
and we largely saw that and we look to
see how that localized around the cell
so we just an increase in expression in
integrand alpha 2 on and bmp4 treated
cells and also on the syste substrates
it tend to localize to the cell exterior
to sell cell context which is consistent
with and mccann sensitive with general
mechanical activity so normally is the
focal adhesions clustering where the
cell could have exerting tension on its
matrix so this is suggesting that the
integral alpha 2 is in fact at cell
borders I think we were particularly
interested in changes in integrand
signaling because integral signal
changes an immigrant's expression is
also strongly associated with cancer
progression
so one of the questions that we had is
what transcription factors are governing
these differences in mechana sensing so
what the field had done Lakes has
generally coalesced around is the idea
that yappin has are these key
transcription factors that govern
Meccano sensitivity so what we're
interested in is that the app has target
genes actually don't seem to be changing
all that much on different stiffnesses
and the differentiate itself so we did
see a few genes that are Yap ties
targets change and the growth factors
stem cell-like cells so we kind of
wondered what transcription factors
could be governing these changes if it's
not yes it does so we look to see what
sequences are upstream of genes that
were mechanically regulated and what
transcription factors bound to those
sequences and which of those
transcription factors were
over-represented so we found the
shortlist of genes we then wanted to
know you know do any of these have some
relevance for cancer because we are of
course studying glioblastoma so we
turned to TCGA which is an online
resource that has a lot of clinical
information is very well as generated so
we like to see which of these
transcription factors seem to be of
interest for glioblastoma
so we particularly honed in on these two
at ESCP 2 in particular because this was
mutated in a fairly high percentage of
cases and also is often done regulated
so this is of course of interest because
if there was a transcription factor that
is important for the kind of something
we might expect that if it's down
regulated the cancer might be more
aggressive because we have this sort of
model where there's lost in the
countess's tivity results in an increase
in invasion so TFTP 2 is downstream of
and on the of a number of oncogenes
we've got a number of names so everyone
seems to know it under a different name
it also plays a role in chemo resistance
and EMT and another
and a number of phenotypes
so it's expression is also or mutations
in this gene also influence survival and
there's a correlation between its
expression levels and how how long the
patient survives after the initial
diagnosis so I think we're pretty
excited to further probe this we have
some experiments in the works so I'd
like to refresh what we've been
discussing so tumor initiating cells so
these are kemp assembly cells sudden I
simply lost on the tumors they are
surprisingly in front of mechanical cues
however we're able to genetically
engineer these cells to activate the
cells contract on mice canary and this
increases the cell's makino sensitivity
as well as reducing their ability to
invade through two dimensional
structures and through small pores
so we can sensitize the cells to
mechanical cues and this inhibits their
the tumor progression in a mouse model
however this isn't the only way that we
can alter how these those process
mechanical cues we can also get
differentiation so differentiation also
the changes how these valves are able to
interpret and chemical cues seen before
up regulates cell or others fell ECM
communication proteins and the MP for
treated cells showed changes in
ribosomal protein and oxidative
phosphorylation genes interestingly the
transcription factors that seem to be
governing these changes aren't canonical
and mechanics transduction and
transcription factors so happens has and
we've been looking at a couple other
transcription factors that do seem to
mechanosensitive
so um with that I'd like to thank my lab
mates particularly my PI Sanjay Kumar
and the undergraduate students is
working with me I'm particularly
Jeannette on this project and of course
my lab mates and with that I'd like to
open it up to any questions that we have
about what I've been talking about
Thank You jasmine for that informative
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of our webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that answer a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started and
take a look at our first incoming
question our first question
Jasmine is you primarily looked at
changes in CAD localization do you also
see differences in why ap nuclear
translocation in your cells on different
stiffnesses
hi-yah that's a really interesting
question we've done yes James in
ourselves you don't see as strong
differences ties and isn't actually also
true for a couple different cell lines
that we've tried it on so neural stem
cells was another felling that our lab
uses early Carly and we don't we find
the tags difference tends to be stronger
than the - difference and I think you
talked about a few other people in the
field that seems to pan out and US and
some other cell types as well
thank you for that our next question
coming in from our audience is have you
looked at the effect that other my ocean
light change activators have in
regulating mechanical transfix I'm sorry
Meccano Meccano transduction in these
cells
yeah so I use the RO a because these
reviews that literally we did that's
what we did our mouth studies with but
we've also done the individual work with
a couple others um rocket roll a pathway
proteins so rock and then also MOC K
which works orthogonal Ichiro way so
that and in combination with of web
statin and similar by clutching
inhibitors lets us say fairly
confidently that the change has to be
seen when they activate really happen
through itemized and contractility and
not through other pathways that really
can act on
thank you for that
for our audience members and for their
participation our next question coming
in from our audience is are all
glioblastoma tumor initiating cells
mechanical sensitive
um that's also really good questions
there's been so we did our work in to
solving both from classics GP and
subtypes and we found that both of these
fellows were mechanically slices however
other labs have done larger panels of
tumor initiating cells and there seems
to be some heterogeneity so some tumor
initiating cells don't our show
completely normal
some sedation to chemicals news however
others do shown as a chemical in
subsidiary scene and particularly
increasingly the cells that show
believes Meccano sensitivity tend to
also be the most invasive so it doesn't
seem to be a universal property but it
does seem to be correlated with how
Ableton's tumors are spread through
tissue and to propagate new tumors
thank you and have you look at the
aspects of other differentiation cues in
addition to bmp4
so we've done some studies with serve
just to show that this has a similar
effect in terms of you know increasing
many differentiation markers and do some
some markers but that differentiation
comes to be a little bit more hundred
genius to get some nosh-nosh variability
because it's not always really clear
what you know what components are in
each batch of theorems so we stuck with
bmp4 because it does have been a logical
relative to finish set yourselves live
in you know embodied and also because
it's you get one cue there's a little
bit perhaps easier to figure out what
the effects are thank you for that
jasmine and you know if you have any
closing remarks that you'd like to
provide for our audience today
um no I guess if you have further
comments or you want to follow up with
me I am available on Twitter that's what
my handle in the beginning that's add
jobs to stay AF underscores hu ghts
yeah why be different people later or
you can find my email on our lab website
as well
Thank You jasmine and I want to do
remind our audience members that if they
have any additional questions they can
email you before I go I want to thank
them for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we also
want to thank you as a presenter and we
want to thank lab roots and our sponsor
a thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through September 2018 lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time everyone thanks for joining us
goodbye
you